stockbridge in Edinburgh an affluent
corner of the city popular with families
and young professionals known for its
leafy parks and Scotland's oldest rugby
ground the Edinburgh north and Leith
constituency is currently held by the
SNP but it is a marginal that used to be
held by labour and the Conservatives
have also been making big gains here
recently their vote share went up by 11
percent at the last election so what
defeat is here make it the man who could
lead the Conservatives into the next
election what do you think of Boris
Johnson um I think he is basically a
public school boy who thinks that
everything is just a bit of a joke and
and it's gonna be quite scary if he's
Prime Minister very worrying prospects I
think he would get through grexit
because I think he means what he sees
but other ways has been sure to be about
for claiming he's a philanderer and
buffoon in my opinion do you think a
good Prime Minister I don't really think
so I mean he's lied many times and on TV
and I mean few scandals and I'm not big
fun to be fair normally when we go out
filming it's really easy to find a range
of opinions that we do our best to
reflect but I'll be honest here in
Edinburgh it's been hard to find anyone
with a good word to say about Boris
Johnson and this matters because at the
last election without the Scottish
Conservative MPs Theresa May would have
been unable to form a government twenty
years after devolution we sat down in
the Scottish Parliament to speak to SNP
leader Nicola Sturgeon it looks
increasingly likely that Boris Dalton's
going to be the next prime minister
would he make a good one no in a world
he was a foreign secretary with a
visible tenure he didn't display any
basic competence or seriousness of
purpose and that job your breaks that
has damaged the UK's international
reputation in the last few years but
close by hiding that Boris Johnson's ten
years foreign secretary has damaged that
reputation he seems to have had a
political career where he's gone out of
his way to because to Sicily offensive
to as many people and groups as possible
so I'm afraid I don't think he will be a
good Prime Minister and I find
it actually quite hard to get my head
right under that knowing everything they
know about them the Tories are even
contemplating putting a mental number
Ted I mean the Conservatives have done
relatively well in Scotland in recent
years what do you think the prospect of
Boris Johnson leader would do you only
have to look at how uncomfortable Ruth
Davidson is whenever Boris Johnson's
name is mentioned to know what the
Scottish Conservatives think about the
prospects of him in number 10 I think
he'll be devastating disastrous for the
Conservatives Yukie Wade but
particularly in Scotland he's seen in
Scotland I think has one of the the
principal politicians who are
responsible for the mace that we're in
over brexit the guy who misled people in
the EU referendum campaign and the guy
who knows says he's prepared to take the
UK out of the EU without a deal and for
most people in Scotland that's a
horrifying prospect in Blackwood's
caused a lot of controversy when he sent
that Boris Johnson was racist is it I
agree with invite for comments and so
you think the bosses what is Johnson has
made or verily recessed comments no I
don't know what's in Boris Johnson's
head when he says those things I don't
know what he's thinking what motivates
and what he actually feels about those
things but if anybody Boris Johnson or
anybody else makes the kind of comments
that he has done saying someone has made
racist comments isn't he made a Muslim
woman looking like letterbox he's the
things I hate to be criticized the
backroom racist well you can criticize
the broker personally I think it's up to
women to decide what the weird and don't
wear but you can criticize the bracket
without being deeply offensive comment a
Muslim woman a letterbox or looking like
a bank robber
some of the things he said about black
people I wouldn't even repeat because I
don't think it's appropriate to do so so
the point I'm making I don't know
whether he just does that for effect to
grab headlines or or if that is what he
really thinks I can't tell but I do
think people who'd prepared to make
comments like that can't suddenly throw
their hands up in horror when people
call them out folder and see that the
appeared to be racist as a result of it
the prospects of the general election
are looking relatively high it's also
if there is a hung parliament with the
SNP be prepared to do a deal with labour
I would want the SNP in Westminster to
be part of a progressive coalition that
could keep the Tories out of office no
that's not be given anybody a blank
check it's about seeing frankly and
candidly to people where the SNP stands
in that picture so you would potentially
go into coalition them I said in
previous general election I think for
more coalitions I would be not
particularly keen on I'm not smaller
parties often do the SNP so of course
the third biggest party in Westminster I
don't think we can be described as a
small party even in that context of
course but I've already said I don't
think I'm not ruling anything I don't
know I don't think formal coalition's is
what we would seek to do we've been
trying to work with Jeremy Corbyn to get
them behind the second EU referendum
thus far that hasn't happened and Jeremy
Corbyn and I say this in all seriousness
if breaks if we have an audio breaks or
a catastrophic breaks that all of the
damage that is done from that Jeremy
Corbyn if he doesn't get off the fence
in a second EU referendum abeer almost
as much responsibility for that as
Teresa me and the Conservatives you say
that you've been working with labour
we've been seeking to build what's your
sense about whether or not Jeremy Corbyn
person he wants to see another
referendum I don't think he does
and I think Jeremy Corbyn and this is me
again it's about the Boris Johnson I
don't know what's in Geneva Conference
head but everything would suggest that
Jeremy Corbyn however he voted in the EU
referendum actually we prefer the UK to
leave the real challenge for labour now
is to decide because they can't keep
straddling this fence of pouching firmly
on it they have to decide what side are
they on are they prepared to see the UK
taken out of the EU potentially with no
deal by a prima nurse Alec Boris Johnson
are they going to now see given
everything that's happened in the past
three years isn't it time to let people
across the UK look at this issue again
and make a decision talking for friends
you've said that you want to have
another independence referendum by May
it's not leaving it a bit late we'll be
out that you you've owned it
well you seem to know more than I I
thought we won't
bu-bye then well if Boris Johnson's
Prime Minister then their likelihood is
that certainly becomes more like I agree
with that but as I said a couple of
times and the position of Jeremy Corbyn
becomes relevant here I think the
prospect of a new deal bricks that has
increased significantly but also I think
the potential to stop that happening if
Jeremy Corbyn gets off the fence is also
in case but why not delay we've got
we're taking legislation right now
through the Scottish Parliament we have
to put that in place we have and I make
no apology for this we've been trying to
get to a point where people have clarity
about the brexit future and then they
can make an informed choice so I think
given everything that's happened the
right timescale is later in this
Parliament I've actually said towards
the end of next year there is a
pro-independence majority in the
Scottish Parliament there's chaos at
Westminster in a minute why don't just
press ahead with it now because she
worried that you wouldn't win no I
absolutely confident that we would when
a referendum we've taken the steps to
introduce legislation I have said we
will have the option of accelerating
that of course I've also said that we
will have the discussion with a UK
government at an appropriate point about
the transfer of power that we recognised
in 2014 it was necessary to put any
legal grounding of the referendum beyond
doubt that doesn't I UK Prime Minister
to have that discussion with right now
that is worth having the discussion with
but there's no doubt that the case for
independence are stronger than it has
ever been and I am more confident of I
was confident in 2014 I'm more comfort
than I've ever been that Scotland will
take that opportunity to be an
independent European nation playing our
part in the water now it's 20 years
since devolution what grade would you
give your record and what was the 20
years of course have seen governments of
different colours I think I'm not going
to get into kind of silly grading I
always think it's a bit you know yes
some vape roads I made a major speech
just earlier this week which you know
set out what I think the record of the
Scottish Parliament is I think it's a
good one this Parliament that we're
setting in just now in just 20 years
which is the glance whip of history is
nothing has become established as the
Democratic heart of our country there
are many things from minimum praising
for alcohol free personal care for the
elderly tuition for universities based
on your ability to learn not your
ability to pee some of the what we've
been able to do in the Health Service
integrating health and social care for
example these the ban on smoking in
public places a whole range of different
things that wouldn't have been possible
without having a Scottish Parliament is
it also a time for reflection about
where things could improve where the
government could do better I mean for
example looking at the Scottish
household survey satisfaction in
education health and transport at the
lowest level since that was launched in
firstly on your question is it time to
reflect as First Minister I reflect
every single day on how we can do better
how we build on our success these public
attitudes to public services you will
find that higher in satisfaction is
higher in Scotland than in any other
part of the UK if so why is it that the
surveys say Lewis level we've lived
through a number of years of austerity
pressure on public services has been
significant but if you take the health
service not only do we spend more per
head of our population than other parts
of the UK we've had the the lowest
accident and emergency we turn things
the best performance than any other
nation in the UK for four years and some
waiting targets are going down there
absolutely we've got a 850 million
pounds waiting times initiative to make
sure we're meeting waiting times targets
but the performance of the Scottish NHS
is better than in England wheels or
Northern Ireland now I remember that
famous picture of you and Theresa May
when she first and took power Geforce
worry for her I as somebody in a
leadership position I know how tough it
is and I know how Lordan leah is and saw
yes on a human level I can have sympathy
with the position she's been in and it's
been tougher I don't think anybody would
deny that I've at times you know like
everybody else I think marveled at her
sheer physical resilience in all of that
the ability to keep going but it's also
the case in I don't mean this and I said
nasty we but she has in many respects
brought the difficulties she encountered
encountered upon herself yes she
inherited breaks it but nobody forced
her to say it the inflamed
simple red lines that then meet her
negotiating position so impossibly
difficult she made key choices along the
way that resulted in her being where she
is so personally yes you know I can feel
sorry for her on a human level but
politically I think she has to take a
lot of the responsibility for the mess
that we're knowing do you think it's
been harder cuz she's a female leader i
I think undoubtedly in some ways yes
probably I think and you know I maybe
take me some time to properly looking
back and reflect on these kind of things
but I do think women in leadership
positions are are judged definitely I
think often you know I think of it some
of the language anonymously caught an
anonymous courts that were used about
which were very very violent for example
I don't think that would have
necessarily happened with that amel
prime minister so yes I do think it's
different but the end of the day you
know within these jobs and we have to
take the responsibility that comes with
them just finally before you go and I
can't wash about the wounds well can't
see the picture in the office
about the Scottish team who are you
gonna be supporting now that Scotland
around Oh forgiveness it give me just at
least 24 hours I know this is gonna on
Sunday but this is a couple of days it
is the morning this is the day after the
night before you care to see first of
all it was heartbreaking for Scotland
last night but our women's team have
really done such a good amount to pray
back into Scottish football this has
been Scotland's first World Cup in 21
years we've scored brilliant goals we've
played some amazing football
notwithstanding the results I'm really
proud of that young talented passionate
team and the patron of the team so I've
got to know them a little bit in recent
times and I feel gutted for them but I
feel really proud of them as well and I
think that team's going to go much
further in the future which was a way of
dodging the question who am i supporting
and obviously when I was out in Nice
with the England Scotland match I was
still in the same hotel as the lionesses
so
you know I don't know let's see I wish
England well obviously I do but asking a
Scottish person the morning after we've
been put out of a world cup to see which
i think is what you're trying to get me
to see that I'm going to support England
just just be a bit gentler orderly than
that please are you gonna be asking for
a referendum on video I tell you I don't
even understand ve I ve are fully but I
hate it after that I think we I think we
suffered unfairly from a lot of awful
refereeing decisions and we lost a
daughter penalty against England in the
first game but that these kind of things
happen I think the thing for me watching
as just an observer is is not the VAR
decisions it's the inconsistency of it
we've had penalties denied that were
awarded against is another game so
anyway I don't want to start sounding
that we were robbed but came to water
very well thank you